todo está casi listo en tampa para el
super bowl pero este año el principal
campeonato profesional de fútbol
americano en eeuu tuvo que adaptarse a
las recomendaciones sanitarias por el
hobbit 19 la liga nacional de fútbol
americano recibirá solamente a 25.000
fanáticos menos de la mitad de la
capacidad del estadio raymond james que
acoge hasta 65 mil personas
estamos emocionados por estar aquí
venimos de cansados ganamos nuestros
boletos para venir al superbowl de manos
de los kansas city chiefs porque somos
titulares de boletos de temporada y
estamos emocionados
los grandes ausentes serán la marca
coca-cola y hyundai patrocinadores de la
emisión televisiva que en 2021
decidieron no gastar millones de dólares
en las siempre esperadas franjas
publicitarias también quedaron por fuera
las glamorosas fiestas donde se crean
los dueños de equipos ejecutivos de las
cadenas de televisión y los amigos de la
liga nacional de fútbol américano en
cuanto a la seguridad durante el evento
la policía de tapas se prepara para
diversos tipos de amenazas desde
manifestaciones de los aficionados hasta
la posibilidad de terrorismo doméstico
los eventos en el capitolio aunque es lo
que está más fresco en la mente de todos
realmente no afectan la forma en que
estamos haciendo las cosas estamos
organizándonos para cualquier tipo de
manifestación no importa cuál sea su
mensaje simplemente queremos que la
gente lo haga pacíficamente
los tampa bay buccaneers se enfrentarán
a los kansas city chiefs todos los
jugadores incluidos los entrenadores e
integrantes de la plantilla se someten
diariamente a dos pruebas de kobe 19
cualquiera que llegue a ser positivo
debe aislarse de su equipo al menos 10
días
pero ninguno ha resultado contagiado en
más de tres semanas